so basically a chicken fillet roll in
Ireland is like
yeah it's a thing that we're absolutely
obsessed with I get one all the time
when I go home bread a chicken generally
and then fillings of your choice you can
have plain chicken or spicy chicken
I go for a spicy have like lettuce
cheese
a bit sweet chili corn sometimes and
they're in our petrol stations so on
this one we've got a bit of lettuce
we've got a bit Mayo chicken cheese here
we go
mmm
good
bread stuff
yeah you can't beat that it's just
beautiful it's just simple well so
effective how does it compare to the
Irish petrol station versions
um you weren't close but it was a good
attempt they appreciate the attempt yeah
the chicken fillet roll wins every time